Geron was telling me this morning that
he loves watching TV especially with his
wife Mary that's their activity and he
loves it no problem right yeah sure
that's good
so he says boss I don't know what I'm
gonna do because I'm watching too much
TV so I bought a jigsaw puzzle I go Gary
I'm gonna stop you right now [ __ ]
jigsaw puzzles are the stupidest [ __ ]
things on the planet you're gonna take a
beautiful picture and someone's gonna
tear it up and you're gonna put it back
together again I said why don't you just
take a Boz smash it in your house and
why don't you and Mary sit there and
glue it back together again because
that's how dumb [ __ ] jigsaw puzzles
walk he goes well it prevents Alzheimers
ball I said first of all when did you
become a doctor you enjoy watching TV
watch TV with Mary maybe that prevents
Alzheimer's Gary what's the picture that
you're trying to put back together like
what is it like a relax is this your
first puzzle or have you done more truly
already came in to warn me that this
will only end in an argument what do you
mean to the puzzle he says like put
together a piece of furniture all they
did was fight plus you know Gary's like
an executive producer on my radio show
no offense he lives his life like he's
retired he's so bored watching TV he's
got an outline puzzles something else it
always disturbs me when I hear what
Gary's up to because I'm like came back
how about throwing in your office and
making a few phone calls Mary I just
bought a box of pick-up sticks I'm gonna
get him a shuffle boy I was on a very
important phone call 8:30 last night for
real all right
and I'll tell you about it during the
break no time no time for your proposal
shall we do all that I can't complain
about how'd you decide on your puzzle
Gary I went and found an art puzzle so I
think it's the puzzle is like 10 great
paintings like a van got you know all in
one puzzle hmm Oh puzzle let's see
Whistler's mother knows a Last Supper da
Vinci may be a lady with a nope no hey
this has got a wall look at I don't have
to choose
I rep the cheers at always like you were
in the room my head doesn't hurt anymore
no more TV for me it's like punishing
himself with a puzzle where are you
gonna do your puzzle with Mary well we
have a lot of room in the house now some
will because nobody's there so we'll do
it on the on the dining room table
probably at some point Mary I got a
meatball on the puzzle maybe the puzzle
shouldn't be on the dining room table I
like the people when you finish the
puzzle Gary will you glue it or will you
just do it again like art this is a
puzzle I did back in 1979 this puzzle
was done recently as you can see the
glue my proud member screen why not you
and Mary do Legos man what about a model
airplane would you mind how about some
Lincoln Logs set very best room I feel
we're getting closer together and I feel
my Alzheimer's will slipping away by the
way silly putty prevents polio
what is this puzzle guess the puzzle
gary has which is made it actually made
my head hurt looking at it yeah it's
like a dozen other famous paintings all
shoved onto one canvas like one of those
like there's like thousands three four
five oh good Majid simply Gary and doing
a thousand-piece puzzle I love it okay
Mary's time to do the puzzle ma'am over
here I think I have Mona Lisa's nose
right before you punch me in the face
you go I love you I do I love you bye
couldn't sit there and do a puzzle with
you all day I would think what a
tremendous waste of time how much time
do you put in on the puzzle every day
like I'd rather Gary watch TV because at
least for work he could talk about he
might find something no you ain't gonna
find anything but like a cure for
Alzheimer's and the puzzles gonna be
sitting there for years what about
playing musical chairs or
duck-duck-goose
maybe the hokey-pokey Mary duck duck
Duck Duck Goose or hide-and-go-seek
hide-and-go-seek would be mmm I can't
find you
you